ah
[Music]
I'm nacho coloma I'm castromán
engineering for google cloud platform
in berlin and today we're going to talk about two things
we're going to talk about how to build a
continuous integration environment that generates
containers that publishes containers and
we're going to talk about how to deploy this using
rulers
am
continuous integration  in environments
continuous integration be continuous be
free and continuous movements continuous
integration are complicated environments and
the first reason is because the
definitions are complex
we can all more or less
agree that continuous integration
means that automatically
anything that I upload to the repository is
test is launched into the battery of tests
with each thing that I want public or
continuous is released when this
apart guarantees you that at all times
I have an application that I can deploy
I have something that can explain and the
last step can be manual where
continuous deployment  it would be the last step it
is automatic  Of course, anything that I upload to
the repository will automatically
test everything and automatically
deploy production and the difference
between continuous free and continuous
deployment comes down to what our
business people tell us if we have
requirements that are not  can deploy
if no manual ok is given or if there is no
say requirement in which case I can
deploy automatically
is usually more driven by
business decisions
and I have a diagram that is more or less
familiar to anyone who has
worked with continuous integration environments
than  it is what comes to be from
day to day and day to day means
making modifications that are uploaded to the
code repository that is uploaded to the
git repository and any icon that
you can see here of products are
simply indicative git
automatically fires a trigger  in
our continuous integration environment
a jenkins a traversal and whatever
we have and it's automatically tested
launches all our test battery
building our the fact and then
publishes the artifact and that last step
can be different for each technology
if we are talking about java we are
talking about a hardware file that we
want to publish on a nexus but we can
be talking about no country  they are
different environments different languages
ent that last step can be diffe
ent and t
is process is generally the same and it do
s not matter what product we are talki
g about we can be talking about infra
tructure as a service I set up my ow
continuous integration environment we wo
ld be talking about good becau
e I have a  linkins I have a git
I have it and spinnaker and I manage my
own environment or we can be talking
about software as a service today I'm going to
integrate with travis and find out if
there is and all I'm going to do is
configure it to connect to my
repository the  process remains
exactly the same and the next step
is to say ok now who  But to take the
next step, I want to be able to deploy
its last step, it can be manual or it can
be automatic, we can talk about
continuous delivery or we can talk about
triply continuous, but what this last
step does is connect
different environments with our environments, the
diagram is exactly the same, continue
being code that is
uploaded to the kitsap repository test battery that is
launched automatically and that which I am
generating automatically I deploy it
in my environment or in another
what is the next step the next
step is to build an image because in
an environment in which  what we
want is to scale as fast as
possible get machines up as fast as
possible build an image and deploy
an image makes our environment
boot faster and there are two
options and I may be thinking of building
an image for a
virtual machine or building  an image for
containers
the process is different the tools
are different that is  if we want to
stay vendor independent
we may be talking about packers or
we may be talking about cloud but the
ones working with google cloud
are exclusively for
container images we may be talking about
docker rockets windows containers
for virtual machines there is an article
written by one of our  solution
architects we're not going to get into that today
but it basically touches on all the
different issues when it comes to building
best practices for building managing
images how do I take care of my
old images how can I delete
an old image if I want to share
an image between projects like how
can i do this and how to guarantee that
your images are encrypted and
secure
so for all this we have an
article we won't go into this today today
we are going to focus more on containers
within containers we are also going to
talk a bit about cuber net is how many
of you  are you familiar with qv
ernet is 16 more or less how they
work
cover yourself is basically it is a
container orchestrator it is the result of 12
years of experience at google working
with board the things we have seen that
work and those that don't translated into an
open source product that is
independent  provider and that can
be deployed on any platform
you can deploy on google cloud just as
you can deploy on
any other
platform today we are proud to say
that more than 50% of the code in q
vernet is not from google  despite the fact
that we made the first release
recover is a really open short project it
is part of let's say the
group that manages linux, that
is, it is released and is donated to
science
and allows it to be independent not only of the
provider but also independent of the
format  of containers that we want to
use if we want to use
docker containers or if we want to use
containers what is c  ooper net is
for
everyone so if I want to start
thinking in terms of containers and I
want to start deciding hey
let's generate containers what are
the extra steps
I still have the same diagram I keep
uploading code here I keep taking
from following  and while continuous integration
continues launching my tests and
building my stuff but when it comes to
building my container I have two
options I can say ok I'm going to launch
docker on my machine in which case
docker is responsible for installing docker
patches with what versions of these
libraries is compatible with which ones not
the problems normally associated with
working when there is another option on
google cloud platform which is to
work with google container wilder
continue build you are a
google managed service we will talk about that
in a second
with which i can choose to install
docker in my continuous integration environment
or integrate with an
external environment and  n where my image is built
my docker image and once built
the only thing that remains is to publish it and to
publish
I still have options and today during the
keynote we talked about what it is
about in google of course since having
options
I can decide my container  that I
want to publish it in docker hub and that is
perfectly valid or I can decide
since I already have a managed service
within my google project I am going to
use this service in the case of
google cloud it is the registry container and it
contains the registry basically what
does is that it stores your image it is a
service because you don't have to pay anything
the only thing you pay is for the
space occupied by those images exactly the
same as if we were using
google cloud storage because what we
are using is google cloud
storage it is a back es  from google cloud
storage
and from there
I want to be able to deploy that image later and to
deploy it is basically that vernet is
what it is  e can be used
usually happens when you talk when you talk
to companies that wait in the
integration environment it contains a
special functionality to be able to
work with containers or to be able to
work with cooper net is that vernetta is
a command line it can be used
within a pipeline of  jenkins a
traversal pipeline is exactly the
same as you know to use any other
tool is to install govern eta is to
run cover net is exactly the same
as is to install it than to run
2 so that is just you can
work with cooper net it is exactly the
same as any other line
today we will have a demo where we
will deploy with governors
we were talking about two new pieces that
we have introduced in this diagram we have
introduced container builders and it has
introduced contains the registry
contains the wilder basically it takes away
from our environment continuous integration
the responsibility to install docker
install what  means sometimes  s
compatibility issues with certain
libraries means sometimes
group user permission issues we can
pull that out of our CI environment
but it's also
auto scaling when our CI environment
needs some
time to build our images
what it can do what it can  to
continue wilder is to take away that
responsibility and that part of auto
scaling all that time it takes to
build the image is this scaling
is part of
google's responsibility not the responsibility of our
continuous integration environment so that
our continuous integration environment
can be lighter  because all the
time that something is going to take to
run is out of the question for
us to worry about it
contains rental it is not only a
tool that can be used on the
command line and it will be what we will use
today during the demo it is exactly the same as
what you would use  stoker to compile  your
image used from cloud container
bill but apart from this it is also a
tool that can be
triggered you can when it has been
executed when a certain code
has been uploaded repository
automatically builds the image and
we will talk about that also in the second
half of this  this presentation
contains the wilder
box autos are automatically integrated with container
registry which is tremendously
convenient when it comes to saying if you give me
a touch file it is the file I am going to
compile it maybe the compilation
includes your own battery of tests or it
can  no and as a final result of
that compilation I will have an image
that image I will publish
automatically in contains the registry
you don't have to worry about permissions you don't
have to worry about how to connect
one piece to the other contains albil de
concón has registry and  they work
directly
from the same box cars
so what would be the next step
the  next step is okay I have
an application code is uploaded it
is passed to the battery it generates my
containers I explain my containers
what happens with the configuration of the
application what happens when I get to a
development team and tell the
development team where  you are going to put the
user and the password to access
your database and the user the
password it seems like this data I tell you
where they are going to end up in the
properties file within my project the ssl certificate is going to be
determined which will be
the next thing  you are going to ask and the
ssl certificate to the properties file
to the same properties file the
problem you have is when the
configuration is part of the
application you are deploying is that
this configuration is not called
operable in google it means that
the box team does not  you have that kind of
control over how that setting is controlled all
of a sudden what you have is
the development team taking all
the responsibilities  skills assuming the
different environments that happens with
development integration testing
production everything is the
development team maintains property
files that go inside my
application or generate
different dropdowns that is not the idea
the idea of the apps factor is I have a singl
dropdown and  it's only
dropdowns it goes to all my environments
I want configuration I want the
user the password to do to my
database that is part of what
I injected into my cluster it is part of
what I inject as secrets as
confirmed in the case of cuber
net so that I can have
a test environment a team environment and a
production environment
if I need parameters to be able to
do to my database they will come to me either
as environment variables or as
files in my system in my
file system but  they are not part of my
dropdown they are not part of my docker image they are
not part of my war file
they are not part of my noch folder  e
is the configuration has to be left
out if what we want are
operable applications
when we talk about native, of course, in
general we talk about a series of
requirements a set of requirements one
of them is the application has to
meet you the application factor has
to be and  we said before operable the
configuration has to be external to the
application the application has to be
a single application that I am going to
deploy in the different environments
simply by changing the configuration
with which it connects
in the application it has to have
integrated monitoring or metrix and all
monitoring all the metrics have
to go to the same place and it has to
be operable answer to the question and
the typical question that
follows is ok and with
microservices the microservices are
fine if you want to take a system to
the cloud or you want to take it  a
container system and at the same time you want to
do the microservices is fine  n but
it is not a requirement and it is perfectly
valid to say I have a monolith I am going to
take the monolith I am going to take it to
the cloud I am going to take it with it and all the
factor I am going to put everything in the
monolith but it will continue to be  it will be a
single application if you are going to
be the only dropdown and the
microservices I will introduce little by
little and it is perfectly valid to do it this
way because we find more and more
companies that are taking it for granted and
we are talking about what we are
talking about  microservices I can't
have one thing without the other so it's
perfectly fine to have one thing without the other
if that's what you want to do and migrating
in phases instead of looking at the whole thing is
optional
when it comes to the point of saying ok like
like all this configuration like like
controlled all this
configure there are three types of applications
there are three types of tools that can
be used when deploying
systems we can be talking about
configuration management  with
tools such as chef for petzold and
above all else what is most seen
out there this time is that everything we all
know
but when we talk about that role at
the soult level we are normally talking
about a type of tool where
you want to configure a machine
completely  that provisions would be
an intermediate step between containers
and containers that provisions
anything you want to do on your
cloud platform that doesn't fit
inside a docker container if
you want to configure pubs app if you want to
configure something related to detector
or something related to  claudio Esquivel
and you want to automate it there we would be
talking about cloud provisioning and
again the same thing the most
popular tool is more because what works
and when we are already talking about
orchestration we are talking about
everything that remains inside my docker container I
governed three months turn yes
you want to use another tool that is not that
vernet is any  anything that remains
inside my container and anything
that I can because being with my
rendering tool what we are
seeing these days a lot more effort
downstairs in container orchestration tools a
lot less effort upstairs
in the configuration management tool
simplifies the process the  know that I
have a container and that I know how to
deploy that container that is
independent of the machine and that my
orchestrator will be able to deploy
in google cloud or in amazon or in
any other cloud provider that I
have in
mind give it more  time on
container orchestration less time on
configuration
management which brings us to the other point
config as code config
as code means whatever
I'm configuring in my cluster is
better if it's also part of my
kit repository it can be the same
git repository  or it may be a
repository that is different and we may
be talking about what  s
writers files los jam files cuber net
en we can be talking about
help charts my own help chart in
any case we are talking about
choosing a code repository and putting
my cluster configuration there
maybe you don't want to put it there  if you think
they are going to go to productions or alone they
should live in the cluster but
whatever the rest
of your server configuration where are my
balances how many copies do I want of my
docker file what is the memory limit
I want to put file everything  that
can be done that is part of your
5o repository
a question that usually comes up when
we talk to clients who are
deploying in the cloud and who are
deploying containers is what degree
of class sharing or at what point
do I want to share my class and at  what point
not
how good I am not going to ask because
maybe not but there is a percentage of
people here who are using the same
cluster for development and for
pr  oduction or for here and for
production
and sometimes the topic comes up talking to
talking to different talking to
different clients
if you have to see you have production in
exactly the same one that will be the
best using different from my space
is basically what happens is that  you
don't have to see that's fine the only
thing you have to know that you don't have to
see and the reason you don't have to
see is because I can
upgrade cooper nets and break the
production cluster when what I want to do is
break the hubei cluster but at that
moment what I am doing for
production or I can upload a
docker container that has gone broke
that has gone on the other hand that it does not
have a memory limit it does not have a
cpu limit and that is  I eat all the memory
and all the cpu of a node and it's ok to get it
wrong actually by design is what we do
but getting it wrong in an environment or getting it
wrong in production are
completely different stories and  So when it
comes to sharing,
separate that today production would be the
first step and use my fish for
the different teams with amy species
in q vernet later you can use a
maximum amount of memory a
maximum amount of cpu for any project
that this team is deploying  so
you can say this team responsible
for the bilin environment and the
user management environment is worth anything
that this team deploys at most
in the team environment and can accumulate a
total of 10 cpu 300 weight that whatever you
define regardless of the
different projects that work
and likewise security can also be configured
by name spaces so I can
define this team can deploy in
these certain regions in these
certain nodes or it is determined in
a certain way
apart from this experimentation is
recommended and fermentation
means it can be  experience in a
development environment you can't
experience u  n production environment you
want to be direct access to your
developers in the development environment it
is highly recommended
that they be able to run cooper net
is directly against the
development environment but not against the production environment
whatever is in the
production environment should  to go through our
continuous integration environment go
through our you guarantee that it
is deployable
and last before before I commented on
the limits of cpu and memory it can be
specified by container it can
also be specified by name space
it can be specified by equipment and  It is
recommended to specify at least the
maximum resources that they can use and
to allow minimum and maximum
resources minimum and maximum cpu minimum and
maximum memory to be the same
value because that guarantees the deployment
of the container
and I have a demo that I wanted to  I wanted to show you
what basically what we are going to do
is that we are going  sa deploy a
jenkins environment and on that jenkins environment
we are going to directly execute a
pipeline we are going to generate a
series of containers
as many as are familiar with
help
a rulers project
is like a kind of templates for
cupper net is a series of environments already
configured that cover tests that can
be deployed basically it is an
application that is downloaded it will be
configured really quickly in the
cluster and then it has
functionalities such as being able to search
and say well then show me the gen
search that searches for all the packages
that exist in gel
me  I can find here a more and
rábita commitments in which I can count
here charts but practically everything
then if I am specifically interested
in looking for a jenkins
they can already have here the name of the month
better
I can find here the name
of the helm chart that allows me to display
a jenkins so let's go let's create
a yankees I have this right now
withe  Connected to a cluster and if I make
control get potts right now I
don't have anything my sabbath class and so we are
going to use gel to install a
to install a jenkins
basically
it comes to me the gel char comes to me already
with some preconfigured values  those
pre-configured values what we are going
to overwrite with in this case with
he jamal values file and we are
oing to generate this it is going to generate th
s chart when it fin
shes executing one of the
hings that it tells us is hey you want to
know what the  passwo
d you're going to have on the server run
this command here so I'll
run this command to find out what
password my server is going to have this is
going to be the password for my
admin user on my server when it's
built I'm going to give the
server time  to get up in the meantime
I would like to show you what we
have just built there is a file ay
ay a values configuration of e-mail by de
ault yang
in  gs you can see here the
configuration that this char has by
default keep the shorts I am more
interested in the values that I have by de
ault for jenkins this is what I can
configure when I am deplo
ing my system by default I can l
unch a char  from helms and I need
this specific charter from jenkins without
having to do anything at all
but normally it is not what
interests us what interests us is to
change things okay and specifically
let's see for a moment what file
we are using to generate
this instance
this  valuable file and mail
I am specifically interested
in this this is the list of plugins that
I think I want to mount
the version of jenkins that live to
deploy is a version that uses q
vernet is to launch my laws because
I am not families to 2 with well  15 in what
I understand a master and a series the
slaves the clips are the ones that are going to
execute my continuous integration pipeline
and  specifically with these plugins that
will be executed inside containers
touch
apart from this I am interested in the
configuration of my agents the
configuration of the configuration of my
laws I am going to use an image that
I have created specifically for me it is an
image that basically  we can see it
now it is an image that basically
has not reached us it has a little thing it
does not arrive is updating and cloud
and that's all that this image has
but one thing that if I am interested in
doing I am interested in setting up a
secret my pipeline goes  to be the following
this is a very simple application not
that we are going to launch a series
of tests one by one as a final result
I want to publish a doctor fayt and to be
able to do that I need to authenticate
my jenkins machine against google cloud and
to do that  I need a service
account
I need a certificate to be able to
connect that certificate I have
configured it in my technical class I am
doing a  unmount any slave
that jenkins my initial and it will have
access to google cloud because it will have
this this certificate installed it will
have this service account installed
basically this would be all two notes
about this one if I do club control
gets secrets
we can see here  the secret is me luis
has already given before this basically is my
secret with my configuration of my being and
taking out and
if I connect right now good
control by the time this has been
launched
and gel has just been launched and probably my
service already  it's working because
I'm seeing here the pod that was
put ding but I'd like to see what
jenkins configuration has been generated
what we're going to do is
I'm going to connect to my pod and I'm going to take
a look at that specific
file the conflict file  xml
from jenkins to see if
everything that should have been generated has been generated and what
we can see here is that the
configuration that we have seen in java has
been translated into  n a
jenkins config in a jenkins xml config
including my image that should
be here
this is the image that i asked it to
install and this is the configuration for
the image that i asked it to run and
this is my secret so that  I have my
secret perfectly configured let's
take a look at jenkins let's
connect the day in 15 and see a little how it
is
this is a jenkins box cars
configured to work with what vernet
is and configured to be able to upload things
to google cloud platform like  part of
our country' line we are going to connect it
with our project in this case I
have before I commented on a very simple project
based on out which is
this one here which is basically a
very silly application with a
jason pass a series of dependencies and such
and what we are going to do is that we are going to
connect jenkins with this project so
that those who are not familiar with
the latest features that
jenkins incorporates jen  kins
lately incorporates the pipeline functionality
you can have in specified code
what your environment is what say the flow
you want to run with each
commit you
make so this million king file I'm going to
plug into this project we're going to
copy this from here
jenkins
multi branch pipeline which means that
this could be executed in different
branches is if I want to deploy a
I want to take off a type of images in
production and a type of images in
development and a type of images I
can decide what I can do by the type
of tag  what am I putting or can I
do it for the branch in which I am
coming
ok
what jenkings is doing now is
connecting with my rest sorry not
yet what jenkins is going to do now is
connect to my repository
what I in 15 for  to do right now
is to connect to the repository and
download the jenkins file and with that
jenkins file it will generate a pipeline
that is going to be the axis  run
automatically so we're going to
automatically have a first
run of the pipeline here
this is running right now
we're going to take a look to see
what jenkins is doing right
now this pipeline that just
ran this jenkins that we've
deployed that is now connecting
with our repository what
is it doing
we return to the project in which
we have defined the pipeline the dating
file who is fine that is easy
we can see we are using
group and in this one it is fine to install
specifically  so that when this when
this country the end this is the
image that will be displayed
for those who are not familiar with
images of the look that has an
image displayed in google contains
registry usually they all start
because a certain stem below the
name  of the project and then the
name that you want to be in the image is worth
in this case we are ge  By giving it a tag
we are automatically generating a tag
that is the name of the brunch followed by the
beal number followed by how many times you have
built this branch, that is, in this
case branch is master and in this case the
vile name is one we can choose
different criteria we say good  well
the name of the tag that I just gave at
this moment in the git repository or in
this case it is the branch and the vil number
my first stage is basically to run
no to install and install all the
dependencies of n pm
install all the dependencies of n  pm
and launch my tests ok that's
basically what we're doing here
is testing this is the
continuous integration part as is the
continuous delivery part continuous deployment
is the next step we're going to build
the image
and to build the image we basically
configure and  clear what we
are doing here configuring the
project configuring the zone
we activate the service account remember
remember that  we said we have a
service account we have set up the
services in a certain directory
what we are doing now is to
activate it we are saying this is the
user with which we want you to
connect to google cloud when you have
to connect
the next step in this at this
moment is to build  the repository
build the docker image what we
are saying here is go to contain
wilder and tell it to contain wilder I want
you to build me the image of this
particular care file there are always two
options you can decide I do the test
first and generate the image of what
later or you can build the
kerr image and as part of that process do
all the testing then we'll talk about that
second possibility
and now it's time to deploy
this is an example like any other of
saying if your branch is this particular
branch I want it to be deployed  in this
environment if your branch is master I think
you describe me in this other environment
we are talking about  of all that all
the committees that go to the
continuous integration branch I want them to go
against the khyber environment all the
whites that go against this other one all
the committees that go against this other
branch I want them to go to this other
cluster
and that's it  it is everything that
our our country line does let's see
how it has gone
so it seems we are already at the point
of deployment
but it seems that everything else has gone
well they have been launching
the tests these are all the
dependencies of  noud that have been
installed I still remember when it was not
lighter than hab
and well we can find that the
dependencies of have not been installed
several times as the last step in this in
this particular end
as the last step in this particular
pipeline I am printing the url in
where this application must have been deployed
and if I click here I
should see this application currently
displayed
what we have just done now h  We have
generated from scratch a
continuous integration environment with a jenkins
I am at 15 it is relying on vernet
is to execute its own nonsense the
following is also configured to
automatically generate automatically build
its own
toquero images and building these
docker images what is here  we are going to do now is to
deploy it as the last phase of our
country' line our plan by line is
defined as part of our own
repository as part of our own
code imprisoned it is always optional and
we could have decided to do it
differently
we can go back to the laws by
please so we have installed our
own continuous integration environment
we have built the images we have
deployed the images but we have
taken responsibility for the whole
process except for two we have had to
install docker in our
continuous integration environment but everything else
we take responsibility  of all that
with  figuration there is an extra possibility
in contain wilder we used
continue wilder only as a
command line that allows us to
build a docker image but
continue wilder is much more than that and
contains contains wilder can be a
continuous integration environment on its
own account one
fairly lightweight continuous integration where I
have no responsibility for absolutely
anything I don't have to be anything
contains wilder has the ability to
configure trigger settings and trigger
settings means when something happens in
this git repository I want it to
automatically wings this I think
automatically build my image
and  there are two options with contain wilder
I can say I'm going to give you a touch
file the only thing I want is to execute
file and all that lacked specifying a
battery of tests as part of the
process you can say ok you want to
build the doctor file you have to
pass  the entire battery of tests to be
able to const  run the doctor file to be
able to build the image that's fine
but you can also specify your
own script and now we'll talk about this in a
second another thing to note here
is the top where it says trigger type branch
or tag
launch continuous integration battery
for each comic  that makes
sure that a brunch is done maybe it
is not what you want to do there are two
options people can work on different
blanches and when the merge
against master is done is when I want this to be
triggered that is an option it would be
brunch or  this war I have brunch
they merge until I don't
spend on that at that brunch I don't want the
whole battery of tests to be launched
I can play with either of the two
in any case once I have defined
this I can go to the next one  step with
tucker file the possibility that I have are
the possibilities that I have with
docker syntax
the other step that I have is the possibility
of using cloud builders gmail
jame  l basically it is a script in
which I can specify each of the
steps that I want to execute and what
I want to be done in that step each
step has to be based on a
docker image all the steps are going
to be executed in  the same folder and what
is left in that folder at the end is
what is going to be worked with so I can
specify I have a first step that what
I want is to work with
a normal linux image and what I want to execute
this command with is  linux image in
this case ubuntu
and I can there are a series of variables
that I have inside me bild.de mail
I can work with a revision there is to
work with a project you want to
work with these variables and they are
automatically replaced and inside
any executable  whatever I want to put
I can simply put it inside my
source repository I want to make
a script beyond the bach script
execute scribes
apart from this what can I say ok
now I want  that you build me a
certain image this is the image
with which I want you to work each one of
the lines that in that mel file is
based on a docker image works in
a certain in a certain
folder and each step inherits the
previous step each  I go to the output of the result
of the previous step and in the end I can
have images or I can not have them
I can decide in the end that I do not want
there to be images I will do a series of
processes
I will make my own story but in the end I
will not generate an image and I will not  I want you to
publish absolutely nothing,
that is optional, but if we specify
images, these images will
automatically be published as the
final result of the cloud
builders process, so if what we decide is to do
continuous integration with continue
builders,
there is absolutely nothing to manage
because the platform  it is managed
by google
any commit that is made in the
git repository automatically
triggers the trigger c  loud builders can
be done by tag it can be done
when they merge on a
certain branch
and at the end when the build is finished if
there are images, images have been configured
those images are
automatically uploaded to contain
rapa laws that we have seen today in
conclusion
is  possible to build images within
our continuous
integration environment our continuous integration environment
can either generate
virtual machine images or if we want a
lighter environment we can generate
images for docker containers
no matter what platform we are
using we have put examples with
jenkins we have used  examples with
contain wilder we can do examples
with six speed traversal we can
really work with any
continuous integration
platform we are interested in the latest
git lab builds are already prepared
to do this type of process
and you can build builds
according to  agree  rdo with
branch according to contact and law a
little again is to give options these
alternatives and decide hey well I
want to work with this certain
environment or with this or with this different environment
that is basically all this was this
was our time we are open
now for question time if anyone
has anyone has questions they
want to ask right now it would be a
moment thank you very much
[Applause]
questions
no one is sure
because there is a lot of content to date
yes tell me
wait a second that we have a
room microphone first many  Thank you for your
presentation. The truth is that it has been very
practical. I
wanted to ask you before, you had
commented that according to him, according to the
different brunches that are generated
and developed, you can
define it in the environments where the clusters are going to
be deployed, for example,
where are they going to be  be
that you define it in the call file
that
dependencies
you have commented before in the pipeline if
you want d  say in the case that modes that
we have taught has been based on the plan
but you can also define it if
we are talking about cloud of containing
builder you can also define it within
the cloud builders have the evil the
star producer mercas taught now
at the end
with any of  the options you can
decide where you want to deploy at the end
you can always do it you can go to a
base file and say in the base file it's
okay depending on which branch
I'm in and I want you to explain here
go because in the end rulers you can
decide where where  you launch it at the
end of the class biltokia mail process
we are going to generate an image and that image
is going to be published in contain record and
display that image with rulers for
example one thing you can do
even before you have published the
image as part of the process  class
built oyamel you can say with what
vernet is hey I want you to display
the next version of the application
that is  this one and you can decide to
deploy one cluster or another is
your decision because in the end you are the one
who writes the line
that is, in some way I can test it
and then later at a given moment you can
decide not to publish
that image totally yes
more  questions
I wanted to ask you commented earlier
that all three could be passed
[Music]
I don't understand very well without making the image
how the tests can be passed
when you are inside this center of your
doctor file and you are
specifying the steps to generate the
image in  In this image, for example, one of
the steps is instant and installs
all the nou dependencies of this
particular project, but the next step
could be perfectly executable npm
test and run all the
tests in such a way that if
that command does not work, the  container is
not going to build the container image
is not going to build so that's
that's one of the options if
we were thinking p  For example,
using having a wilder is perfectly
valid for many many possible environments,
but if you have within your
battery of tests integrations with the
database that are complex and that
you want to do things
with, probably having a wilder could fall
short and you would have to  go to a spinnaker
or a young jin qing
but here too
hello good look at me the technology is there
the truth is that I really like it I find it
super interesting
basics to start being
we talk about
gubern & it's training containers between
a continuous integration which of the
three  governors
input turbines what I would recommend is not to
enter the documentation from scratch
because the documentation is a little
variety is a bit strong the
tutorials and the examples that the
cooper net test has is that
the code lapse of rulers are quite good
with the aps with the app store
cloud google.com I think that is what you can
also see outside in the bulls too
there is also a bus of code apps in
the colts they are quite good to
start with to get a little trick with
this the tutorials the ones that have
starter there are a series of examples that
come quite well they work with
wordpress with mysql you can get a
little perspective  about how it is a bit
oriented towards the environment, which
has very little learning curve,
that is, it processes in that sense when
you immediately go to comfortable senses and
you are going to see a little how the subject is going
and once you are there I know the two
you are as concurrent as two with two
that you can already think about the next
step which is okay now this to the
continuous integration environment but my advice
would be before experimenting and
normally
feel comfortable with governors and with
docker it can take a day it can take a
day between a  day and two you can already
feel as if you have never had
experience before with what the
attendees
now I had a question regarding
the question of  and the monitoring of the
containers in the
continuous integration process in the
previous talk with enrique we saw a
cv vernet console in which it gave you
information about
that which is
running and but it really does not have
that use in prizes for example
no  you have a console that provides you with
all the information and the console that
shows you the pods the services
replicates them sets that console comes by
default in any governor deployment it
is part of your class it is not
a specific product of google cloud it
is something that  In any case, you have
the container engine console, it's something, it
's something different from having
Google's managed service in place to
work with Cooper Net, but the
console that has been seen from behind, seen
services, is that the console that comes
by default with  q vernet is
from a more practical point of view
i usually feel much more comfortable
with command line for 90% of
things  if you want to see what i say i know p
used by all of us we talk about something
different but for 90% of things
i feel much more comfortable with the
command line because basically i can
build my own console with a
series of gilles simon bases and
constantly seeing how many  all the
services like my deployment go I
can set it up with a command line like in a
command line without relatively much
effort it is quite simple there are a
lot of presentations where in
all of them you will see in the end that everything is
done on the command line and it is quite
easy but  if you are interested in
the console the web console that comes by
default in the governors cluster if
I am really interested in the
command line too and the next one will ask if
there is any utility like something existed
so what do you recommend to monitor
all those processes produced
within  You
can ask me for the container, but why could I
tell you to deploy if what you want to
do is supervise and  The state of your
cluster you have to be graiver
within what is google cloud you have a
promise
if you want to explain your own your own
cluster would be the two typical ones that I would
recommend to work with that
in terms of control monitoring console
is graiver is well integrated
by default with container engine and it
works box data managed by
google permissions you would have to
install lotus they are not the only two
there are many more
we have a last minute
and if not what we can do is
take advantage after the after the
talk and through the corridors  For any
questions, I'll be here all
afternoon, so if you give me the
easy ones and want to ask
anything,
we're here, thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]